to finish on with any on any big note
rather we wanted to show how the area of
software verification it has importance
and growing importance but it's a deep
area and it's an area where there's lots
of fascinating things going on as
illustrated by the comments from my
colleagues here on the panel so well
thank you for listening cheers guys
fascinating stuff Sarah pietra her in
there with Andy Gordon jasmine Fisher
and Byron cook so there's a really nice
kind of flow through the through the
concepts this afternoon so in Andrews
keynotes we heard a lot about Microsoft
researchers expertise in programming
which then led to that discussion on on
verification and we kind of went from
failure to F sharp there I guess didn't
we hear so and Jasmine obviously was
telling us all about verification in
biological systems which leads us very
nicely onto Stephen D mots work he's
head of the computational science group
at MSR as we heard there in the keynote
easel say professor of computational
science at Oxford and he's going to pick
up on and develop the biological theme
telling us a little bit more about what
to me is an absolutely fascinating area
seeing the biological entities as
computing structures so let's hear now
from from Stephen here is
okay thanks very much refers to
everybody for coming about half the
people just left and muscle surprised
because I knows I've even heard this
talk before I can understand it if they
had so so in the next 15 minutes in fact
four teammates by the time I've said
this bit I want to try and do my best to
convey three simple ideas that we're
working on in my lab and principally
through Andrew Phillips's work who under
Blake mentioned earlier and the first is
a sorghum Lee a very high-level
apologies so the first is that there's
going to need to be a transformation and
sooner the better of the way in which we
think about biology and ultimately
understanding complex living systems is
going to require us to think about
biology as computation the second is
that in thinking about biology as
computation it's going to open up the
possibility of being able to program
biology program life and the third is
that if we are able to solve what a
fairly considerable challenges at the
moment in being able to program life it
will have it as the potential at least
to be at least as important in the next
50 years as programming silicon has
proved to be over the last 50 years so
with my 14 minutes or my watch says
three I think we're running over I'll
sort of crack on if I find for to do so
so why life is commutation well I think
to put this into context for about the
last 50 years or more depending on your
point of view the biologic community is
really focused on thinking about biology
as a as an increasingly bewildering
array of parts and it's important to
point out that typically the biologists
and I am born so I'm feel as I can I'm
happy to be critical of my own community
as they need to be the biologic
community of increasingly thought about
those parts and studied them either
outside of the system in which they
operate or in a system that's not
working properly i did a disease system
system that's dead and that's not that
helpful on over the last 10 years I
suppose the systems biology community
other systems biology domain has really
kind of tried to extend that by looking
at the interactions between those parts
equally in systems that typically either
not working properly or system that's
dead or looking at those interactions
outside the system in which normally
operates now this so-called spectacular
success of molecular biology over the
last 50 years as resulted in the fact we
don't even still know how a cell works
and that's not surprising given the fact
that using the same sorts of approaches
we would never learn how a radio works
so what's clear is that there needs to
be a fundamentally different approach to
understanding the problem of you know
what does biology do in understanding
living systems which actually is
required as a previous important
precursor to an much talked-about
unneeded revolution in medicine and I'm
going to come to that right at the last
right at the end so why computation well
is I would argue is as good as idea as
any given the fact that we still don't
know how a cell works for 50 years of
Spector so-called spectacular success of
molecular biology don't need to abandon
the notions of molecular biology though
and I think that I think it's most
importantly at the level of a cell which
is the rather than the gene i'm selling
not other part it is the given of father
this hell is the fundamental unit of
biology and of life that's where we need
to start looking that has to be the sort
of basis and if you look at the cell
everything that cell does is computation
you know the only thing that cell really
needs to do it was so the only things
sensing communication information
processing decision-making your moment
to call battery optimization energy
optimization and evil even virus
detection that's really all I sell those
and that that's that that's basically
the entire thing that keeps an organism
alive and all of those things are
effectively information processing and
biological computation tasks in short
there's no survival without computation
for a cell or an organism
so the molecular machinery for
implementing all of those computational
biological computational tasks are
contained in a way mount to call a
molecular program and let for the for
argument's sake for this talk let's just
say the principle molecular machinery is
DNA there's a discussion to be had about
RNA RNA and a range of other proteins
but that's all for this talk and so
before I can sort of get into the talk
there's a number of interesting things I
just remember important things I just
want to say quickly about the difference
and they're obvious things between
digital software and what mark to call
living software the first is that you
know the last 50 years of digital
software has been based upon this sort
of ones and zeros running on silicon
that runs in your hardware the living
software that your cell has four letters
four amino acids and either appeared in
CG or 80 and that's very different from
the way in which we think about
computers today but but we've got you
know six point something 6.7 billion
proofs of concepts that biology does
computation very well just sometimes
very different sorts of computation
every one of those cells you've got 10
to the 15 cells every one of those cells
has three billion of those base pairs i
talked about cg or 80 that means that
there's two meters of DNA packaged into
six micrometer package which is the
chromosome and so what does it do well
first of all it does programs
self-assembly so you go from this
molecular program via a stem cell to the
assembly of 10 to the 15 living
computers so it's you and me in this
remarkable is remarkable sort of process
where the software creates the hardware
effectively so you imagine buying
windows 8 all we have to do is take it
home on and wrap it and actually build
your laptop but that would be that would
be great it might cost you a bit more
than it does now but that's fine so the
other thing it does is of course this is
a wide range of biological computation
tasks I'll just mentioned two in the
of time here first is a your immune
system is basically an excellent
biological computation system is the one
thing between all of us in this room in
the cemetery because we're constantly
bombarded with viruses and pathogens of
one sort of another 24 hours a day from
birth to death and all lyrics system
does really is his biological
computation it just does information
processing if it does that information
processing well it keeps you alive if it
stops doing it you die or if it makes
errors so that's this is an amazing
information processing a biological
computation computational system
similarly the only reason why you're
able to see me and the only reason why
you're able to see this wonderful cube
on the screen here which actually
doesn't exist is because of the
biological computation that's occurring
in every one of your retinal ganglion
cells your lateral geniculate nucleus an
area v1 in your visual cortex that
enables this remarkable feat of
biological process in which is your
brain and in particular I think the
visual system is that is pit epitomizes
the remark the wonderful competition
that occurs in the brain so just to sum
up at that part of the talk you know
what does 15 10 to the 15 orchestrated
living computers look like well for many
in this room it looks like me many many
many of you will be surprised about that
fact of living computation but you'll be
even more surprised to learn that Paris
Hilton is 10 to the 15 living
computational systems and that may come
as a bit of a surprise to some but if
it's any consolation so is grass so
every cell in every ear of wheat
basically performs information
processing when it wakes up every
morning about what how much
photosynthesis to do how much nitrogen
to fix how much energy energy to devote
to a particular task in order to grow
this thing called food again I'll return
to that at the end of the talk and trees
wonderful information biological
computational devices systems
information processing systems every
morning a tree wakes up has to decide
how much energy to devote to
photosynthesis or to growing or two
nitrogen fixation or to its roots or to
evaporative appetizing and that's a very
dynamic task that's done every every day
by every cell in every leaf of every
tree on the planet and there's something
like three trillion of them absolutely
amazing biological computation in action
I'm going to return to that later on at
the end of the talk as well so on to the
second bit understanding life is
computation opens up the possibility of
being able to program life and in the
broad sense of the term I think I just
want to sort of say there's some some
generalizations here which in some sense
scientifically not helpful but for these
purposes for this suffice so we can
think of the notion that underpinning
the notion program life is that sequence
determines function and if we can design
the sequence we can design theoretically
clean design design the function so the
two challenges to that the first is the
physical implementation of a novel
program inside a cell or inside their
genome and actually it turns out to be
that turns out to be one that's being
tackled very well we know how to do this
and there are two ways to do one is
through DNA strands but these are the
two main areas there are some others one
is through DNA strand displacement which
is which is what we're working on
another one is to engineer genetic
circuits in cells which we're also
working on I'm just going to I'm going
to talk about the former in a little bit
more detail in a moment so DNA strand
displacement um you if you sent the
interesting about this long to meet a
bowl of of DNA in each one of your cells
is if you if you heat it up it unravels
the double helix and you can separate it
and do things with one strand another
and if you cool it back down it will
actually go back into the double helix
so you know you hold you a bit of DNA
over your kettle unravels and then you
sort of do what you want with it in
terms of inserting somewhat some and
some design DNA that's challenged to
which I'll come to in a moment so what
this really means in a bit more formally
is the consequence of what's called
watson crick duality is that pairs will
only hybridize meet together if they're
actually going to perform some function
and they can do and and can perform some
function if they don't like the pair's
don't match they were just won't do it
so will it will it will it will it will
it won't bind so DNA is also separates
into two domains one is called a short
short strand of DNA which is called
toehold DNA which is what the tea is
here and the other one is what's called
in this let's call it body DNA or
specialized DNA which is much longer
sequence of base pairs and if you want
to do stay at DNA strong displacement
you get your DNA over a kettle you
unwind it and then what you can what you
can do is in the top bit here we have
how we have our let's say let's say
that's our designed bit of DNA implement
some function and we want to replace the
design bit so we want to replace the
ordinary bit which is the bit on the
bottom with the design bit which is on
the top so what we can do there is an
each pair as a complementary base which
is what the tea symbol is so what we can
do is if if the DNA is going to do
something the design DNA you get the
toehold it will bind it through the
toehold part of this of the strand and
then go towards fully migrating if this
if it's not going to perform some
function that will bind that that's
reversible and won't bind but if it is
going to perform some function it will
bind and then displace the original
strand and you're left with a new strand
of double helix DNA which is your
designed part which should do something
novel in terms of function as a
simplification but that's basically it
challenge to which is the biggest
challenge is the design of new function
itself and that's the that's our primary
focus we do do DNA strand displacement
but the biggest challenge and if solving
this one would be it would be a massive
advance in our ability to program life
is how can we design how do we do the
rational design of new function because
the way in which strand displacement is
done at the moment it's basically sort
of it's like just a mechanical process
it's really in this in this in the stone
Age's this would be even pre prior to
the advent of valve computers in the 50s
and the 40s so what we've been working
on again principally andrew phillips has
been leading this work is on a language
for programming life and i'm going to
quickly go through it so he needs the
language for programming life is as you
do with any other program is
calculus and syntax I'm not going to
blow on this in interest of time you
need an in that software environment for
designing a DNA program which we've done
you need to be able to simulate that DNA
program which we're also able to do you
need to able to then compact compiled
that program actually to DNA itself
which we're now able to do then you can
manufacture that design DNA or the
minute is what's called oligonucleotide
DNA so basically so fairly short DNA in
the scheme of things not two meters and
then you can insert that into a cell and
get the cell get the cell or systems of
cells to perform some novel function and
where that we are able to actually get
cells living systems to perform some
novel function it's fairly simple normal
function at the moment but it's very
early days they just just cracking these
challenges is a big advance so just to
conclude programming biology so we're
very we're all very excited about all of
that law even though there's lots of
challenges still and still to be to be
overcome so programmed by biology has at
least as a potential at least to be at
least as important as programming
silicon over the next 50 years as
program in silicon has been on the last
50 years I just want to mention a few
important ones so I think thinking about
biology as computation and life doing
biological computation I think would
totally transform the science of biology
biology but biological science and
systems biology and I think would usher
in a new field of biological computation
as opposed to computational biology and
that's again that's very early days but
that's we're beginning to sort of make
some headway in thinking about and an
insult of pioneering a field of
biological competition the corollary of
that or it is basically if you do that I
think it will just show in potentially a
profound revolution in medicine again
this is not without its challenges but
you imagine being able to repair
congenital diseases in the womb through
being able to actually repair DNA so far
is so for example some some interesting
ones and some important
ones are things like listen carefully
subcortical bamboo heterotopia of Miller
dykey syndrome so really profound brain
defects which are not possible to detect
prior to will certainly passed the
termination date of birth of a baby so
you so the baby has to be born but
babies never look beyond about six years
old it's actually we know that we'd
actually we don't really know a little
bit about how we might be able to repair
the gene on chromosome 17 to be able to
actually unwind that that congenital
brain disorder in in the embryo for
example again a long way off but just
give you an example I'll just give you
an example or in immunotherapeutics is
really kind of a new area that that will
really require our ability to when the
immune system goes wrong to be able to
repair it using programming life
techniques computing as I said you know
there are at least six point seven
billion proofs of concepts that come the
biologist computation reasonably well
it's just in many senses a different
form of computation to silicon computers
but it may well be the case that the
foundations of the next century of
computing might be in biology I don't
know it's it's exciting to think so
though energy you know what I by 2040
there's going to be 9 billion people on
this planet and currently there are no
known ways unless we start building a
nuclear power station every week which
isn't happening currently of how we're
going to power the planet with nine
billion people on it and the UN recently
said that by the end of the century
there may well be between 10.1 and 11
billion people on it and there is no
known way that we're going to pay able
to power the planet using using existing
approaches and but yet there's enough
sunlight falls on the planet every day
to be able to power the planet with the
population of much greater than 11
billion the fact of the matter is of
course that we're living on ancient
sunlight but if we were able to find a
way to live on real-time sunlight that
might solve our problems and of course
trees have solved that problem in
photosynthesis so he imagined being able
to actually learn from how trees do have
since this much better and being able to
not just not just mimic that but
engineer trees artificial
used to do artificial photosynthesis and
one can one might imagine it sounds
absolutely crackers now but one might
imagine a day where there are a trillion
artificial trees running a trillion
living software applications powering
the planet doing artificial
photosynthesis and that you know people
are beginning to take that not true not
many people but people being to take
that seriously but that's fight and then
finally you know equally probably the
biggest challenge of all as I said
there's going to be at least nine
billion people on the planet by 2040 and
it may well be up to 11 billion people
on the planet by the end of the century
there's absolutely no known Wayne no
government every I've got every govern
that knowledge is that there's no known
solution to them at the moment to being
able to feed a population of 9 to 10
billion people so whilst it's all it's
very nice of us in the in the west of
the developed developed nations so thing
that we don't need to think about
engineering foods for a population of
even 6.7 billion there you know there
are already one and a half billion
people who don't have enough food every
day and it's estimated that may well be
over three billion people by the middle
of the century so we do urge initely
need to think about ways in which we can
engineer food for a burgeoning planet
and programming crops to be able to be
more resistant to drought and more and
increase yield in ways that are not
currently possible is something we have
to consider and may well prevent a
catastrophe by the end of the century of
billions of people starving to death
that's it thank you very much
it's a fascinating stuff first it's
stephen e mot there so say we'll keep
things moving along because things very
kindly made have a bit of time actually
by banging through those slides really
really quickly so we'll keep the
momentum